hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
Sally Sally Lomonaco welcome back here
we're gonna watch this trailer I'm gonna
butcher this I feel like there's an
extra e syllable here that I don't know
if I'm supposed to pronounce it or not
called jungle jungle e it looks like it
takes place in the jungle so I'm
assuming it's just called jungle and
there's just two E's we're off to a
great start here today people I Indian
Hindi language very much so this is like
an action thriller and it's blown up on
the internet right now sure my brother
Jabby Kawai has already seen this a
bunch of times but it's directed by an
American guy who directed such films
such as the mask eraser that's where
Arnold shits a crocodile at the zoo did
not give me any and the Scorpion King
you know did they oh damn I hope none of
them get hurt 100 elephants just to
choose the perfect for Sally did
research Wikipedia on the page that was
at the time let's check this out you
know we like our third largest
demographic third or fourth largest
demographic on the channel is actually
our Indian subscribers well most of them
do come from my brother's Channel you
know every once in a while I will watch
an Indian video for you for you guys
specifically
yeah I need a best friend of those how
many those thinner
I was a nice film yeah well this was an
action
Oh
hello well played
Oh Danny's got martial art skills
no he's crying some animal died who is
this guy oh [ __ ]
am i want to see this guy's movies tell
me what he's been in guys
yeah I want to see that so bad
welcome to the jungle [ __ ] dude that
is like the way you do a modern-day
jungle book movie right he reminds me my
dear me when I look in the mirror what
the dude from the mummy and Brendan
Gregg Alba reggae album Rachel I started
the mummy and The Mummy Returns man
Brendan Fraser yeah yeah he was my stunt
double in the mummy yeah I know people
get confused I love this like initial
thing where I'm like did I miss read all
my information this is like an animal
activist beautiful movie where this
guy's as long as I love watching those
kind of videos where you know like
people just hang out on the jungle and
bond with the animals the people were
like and then they get near them you
just know how to treat them properly and
you got this guy who just happens to be
the most muscular dude in the world who
knows how to bond with him and then he's
kicking ass against poachers man like
fighting for the animals and everything
like that and then for the dudes like
yeah kick these guys asses this is so
cool and the fight scenes do look pretty
badass I mean I can move like that when
I go to the boxing room at LA Fitness I
tend to do maneuvers like that on the
bags and then I get called out because
there's signs posted everywhere on the
mirrors that say do not kick the bags I
can't help it I just gotta flip off the
bags and show some kicks off he pretends
approaches I pretend they're poachers
kicking poachers asses left and right at
the gym sometimes I harm individuals it
happens I loved it I was not expecting
that I was expecting a super serious
like gritty movie for some reason but it
was it looked really
fun it looked like I had all the
elements I'm excited to see it like why
am i more excited for that movie than
like anything coming out in America
forget Avengers endgame people
spider-man far from home can stay far
from home
jungle II did she jungle II my god some
wonder should have been a parenthesis
with a pronunciation yeah there's so
much the force well dude I mean if this
guy this is based on a real guy I was so
taken aback because I I was going in
with the same kind of expectation level
you had oh this is probably to be like
some really serious gritty so that I'm
sure it's gonna have its serious
elements that point when he stood up he
was a little misty-eyed so there's gonna
be animal deaths to be had in or for it
to be impactful you got to get some of
that revenge some vengeance going in
here which means my girlfriend can't
watch this Olivia it cannot watch this
movie yelling at the screen and like
when an animal dies in a movie it she
can it can be rough for her like dickham
is her watch for John wick right and I'm
like don't worry I'll skip the dog death
scene right skipped it successfully
boyfriend points and then when he's
cleaning up the blood there's just a
flash of a whimper of the dog and just
put her in a terrible mood and she's not
the only one I know who's like that
there are people who really cannot
handle animal deaths in movies I could
pitch this to her saying hey but babe
you know it's about like kicking those
[ __ ] of asses the [ __ ] for
killing them but you know still it'll
probably bother her god you mean this
guy's so hot maybe she'll forgive me
it's gonna hurt or making her feel like
this was a great decision
kind of want to watch it alone as would
VR goggles this is crazy because I don't
think the Scorpion King is a very cool
movie and erasers a very guilty pleasure
of mine so the fact that this guy who
seems like his last movie was the
Scorpion King to be doing this Indian
film is pretty crazy to me he might have
found his new market to tap into man
Chuck Russell way to go buddy I'm happy
for you
this is the way unite countries and it
does have some jungle book vibes
yes this guy's totally not real that's
true hey we're buddies honestly I would
have liked this movie a little bit more
if he killed the snake I hate snakes I
really do true story when I was 16 years
old I was helping clean leaves at a
person's place I was gonna pay - it
wasn't holiday - that at the end yeah a
snake appeared just right right right my
feet and I hit with a shovel I killed it
it wasn't a snake its legs recovered by
the leaves it was a lizard
you killed a salamander yeah and now
your time is up I'm officially off the
channel again I felt very bad about that
I'm glad to get that out there now
there's Greg telling the truth he really
is that's the sad part I woulda liked
him more if he killed the snake but it's
cool that they're taking a whole
approach here where he likes all animals
and all animals are equals there's dance
moments in here I don't see the dance
moments looking forward to this and this
guy looks like he performed his stunts
soms it says right here I want to see
more of his movies so guys comment below
and tell me what other movies he's been
in and hey before we wrap this up I like
to give a patron the day shout out to a
man named Niraj Krishnan he lives all
the way in New Jersey she is in fact
Indian hi Raj Raj is a very friendly
dude he started checking out IMAX films
because of my recommendation
I know alright calling her n he's a big
fan of both myself and my brother
Jabba Kuwait he has stated on multiple
occasions that he prefers Jabby Kawai
over me and after that I decided I'm no
longer gonna message him back on patreon
he goes a big part of what fuels me so
Niraj I'm sorry I'm glad you're still
pledged even though I will ignore you
for eternity don't consider this an
acknowledgement of you this is my way of
telling you it's over Niraj but I still
have you nervous that Sally's so lazy
please stay pledged to pilot your on
digging they're digging Sally guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell what do you think
of the movie jungle Lee Sally's on the
youtubes go check her out